oh bonjour là,
vous vous demandez peut-être pourquoi le costume rose
pour que le monde puisse voir que j'ai un grand
cœur sur ce cœur avec le T pour
ma nouvelle obsession rose la couleur pas la
chanteuse pop personnellement je suis plutôt du
genre saline de  le gars
rose se cache comme un beau ruban pour
une cause très proche de moi, le cancer, tellement
étonné et je me réunis pour effrayer de l'
argent sérieux
pour baiser le cancer, je vais faire don du
même costume sur mon dos tout en vous donnant une
chance d'en posséder
souvenirs de marketing cinématographique ce que vous faites à partir de là n'est
limité que par votre imagination l'
ajouterez-vous à votre rotation hebdomadaire de garde-robe
qui ne deviendra pas un
ajout coloré à votre donjon S&M oh vous le
clouez simplement à un poteau afin d'
effrayer les oiseaux les enfants  et les
personnes âgées visitez le site Web ci-dessous pour obtenir
tous les détails c'est un combat où
tout le monde peut être un héros pas de
capes de superpuissances ou de costumes CG boiteux besoin juste de
votre argent sérieusement nous avons besoin que ces
costumes ne soient pas bon marché adieu étonné calme en
avant  -slash Deadpool et ensemble
laissons le cancer vous calmer